we're starting this is the first
official session of our bioinformatics
for infectious disease program we are
starting today on May 4th and this
program is going to have several
sessions like today they're going to be
different types of sessions they're
going to be more informational sessions
where we will do we will have different
speakers covering different subjects and
doing some hands-on analysis and then
we'll do some Q&A sessions well you will
be able to ask any questions and we'll
focus on the types of problems and
challenges that you have as you go
through the program at the end of this
month we're going to also provide enough
time for everyone that wants to work on
their own bioinformatics projects to
actually apply some of the skills that
you've learned throughout the program to
a dataset of your choice but in this
program we're focusing on bioinformatics
for infectious diseases so that includes
viruses bacteria we won't touch on other
pathogenic sources but we will focus on
a couple of examples a few examples
coronaviruses Ebola rhinoviruses flu
tuberculosis so the viruses that we hear
about a lot and some bacterial
infections as well so the goal of this
program just to kind of give everybody
an overview is to understand some of
these pathogens and the diseases that
they cause we'll talk a lot about
different animal hosts where a lot of
the adaptation of these viruses and
bacteria happens before they actually
come and in fact and cause these kinds
of diseases and endemic outbreaks we'll
talk about viral evolution replication
so what are those processes include I
will talk a little bit about bacterial
infections as you know viruses infect
bacteria and so that interaction between
bacterias and viruses are important for
us to understand viral evolution and
replication and
hosts like animals and humans have a lot
of bacteria and so viruses and bacteria
and humans or hosts animals are an
ecosystem so we'll talk about that and
we'll talk about data so this is a
program focused on bioinformatics so
we'll talk a lot about data and the
primary type of data that we'll be
talking about is next-generation
sequencing data in fact this session
today is dedicated to an overview of
next-generation sequencing data in
application to these types of problems
what types of analyses will we talk
about we'll talk about the different
strains and haplotypes and so
specificity identifying exactly what is
the pathogen that we are that is causing
disease we'll talk about how to
characterize novel viruses by looking at
similarity and differences we'll also
talk about the metagenomic communities
of the microbiome and how composition
and differences in the microbiome are
associated with different infectious
diseases we'll talk about vaccine design
antivirals and antibiotic or antiviral
in antibiotic resistance what are some
of the next-generation sequencing data
types and bioinformatics analysis
methods that are used to study that kind
of resistance and we'll also talk about
different specific projects and datasets
that will help illustrate some of the
methods of analysis that we discuss in
general in a specific use case so I will
focus a lot on the epidemics like Ebola
Zika and dengue or Rhino virus and
enterovirus d68 and so talk a few about
a few different examples and we'll also
talk about
some of the long-standing epidemics like
tuberculosis for example where there are
other types of problems that are caused
by the way we treat these diseases so
before we go into today's session and
the topics related to next generation
sequencing I do want to make sure that
everybody understands the registration
process and if you are already
registered you know where to find the
different resources that we're going to
be referring to in in this session today
and we'll try to eliminate any kind of
confusion or you know make sure that
everybody has on links and is able to
access everything or if you're not then
you know how to get there so I'll do
brings overview I do want to mention
that we dedicated a full session to this
last Friday and we do have a recording
of that session that perhaps beach' can
place and chat for anyone that's
interested to understand all of the
topics that we're talking about here
today as an overview of the program and
what is the process of registration and
all of that we'll have a link here in a
few minutes in chat for you to review so
first
just briefly there's going to be a
registration page where you have to fill
in your details we asked their
information like your name email contact
information location and things like
that and so based on that information we
then email you a link where you can
register for free on the portal that we
run an educational portal so you'll have
to register by creating a username that
is going to be associated with your
email address and then that free account
is what could be added to this program
the program is paid and there's a link
on how to complete your registration we
don't expect everybody who is interested
in bioinformatics to want to pay for
this program so if you do want to just
refer to some of the free resources that
we have we have that as well so make
sure that you create an account you can
find some of the free resources create a
demo account on the platform that we'll
be using today and you can still benefit
from learning like that if you do want
to join the program make sure that you
are looking for this kind of an email
after you complete the registration form
and in this email there is going to be a
few links on how to actually do that and
so that was the first webinar that we
did to cover the program overview and
then today we're actually starting the
program but we're going to keep the
registration open until the end of this
week the reason is because some people
had different we're not ready to
complete the registration and so we want
to make sure that we provide a good
overview before we close the
registration by the end of this week so
for those of you that did register I
want to make sure that you have all of
your login information so there is going
to be two different logins and one of
them is for server T bio info this login
information is emailed to you those of
you that are registered to
they might not have gotten that rich
that login information just yet it will
take up to 24 hours for you to get that
information and then here as I mentioned
you register for free and you will see
some free resources here so just make
sure that you have this information if
you don't you can reach out to be chat
whose email is marketing a pint bio so
if you have any questions about
registration please ask her to help the
program and I'll do a little review of
those of you that already registered for
the program what are you going to expect
to find so there is a link let me in
fact go there on this link you will find
a lot of relevant information for what
we're going to be doing throughout the
program so if you go to the main portal
which is edu dot T - bio info let me
place that in the chance
okay so that's the main portal and in
this portal you'll be able to go under
events and you'll see bioinformatics for
infectious diseases so that is the
program that we are going to be talking
about today so please go to this link
and once you're logged in you should be
able to see what I am seeing on my
screen and that includes primarily the
schedule so you will see here the
schedule for this program by navigating
this outline and you can also see a lot
more detail related to the program right
here so we started talking about this
last time there's going to be a forum
for questions if any of you have
questions for us to answer or for other
participants to answer you can post your
questions there that's also where we're
going to be posting recordings from
previous sessions and so make sure to
check that out and for those of you that
are not joining the live sessions you'll
be able to see all of the review
material here and you can see that beeps
are already posted here a welcome
message there's going to be another tab
those are courses for the participants
of the program all of these courses are
free and they're not required but they
will help you get a sense of the
different types of projects and analyses
that we will be covering in this program
and there's also going to be projects
progress assignments and here you'll
find a number of other useful links that
we'll discuss here in a few minutes
okay so an important part of it is just
to make sure that you have your login
and you've completed your profile
registration if you go to members you'll
find a list of the members that have
joined already and then you'll be able
to register and then you'll see your
name and profile here I don't want to
you know highlight anyone just yet but I
do want to mention that some of you have
completed your profile what's important
in completing your profile is actually
making sure that you have I'm sorry
Kevin I'm going to highlight your
profile because we were able to complete
a lot of the a lot of the information
about you so what's important is to have
your full name that will appear on your
certificate at the end of the program so
it's important that it's not you know
new guide 24 or some kind of weird name
so please fill out your full name we
also encourage you to complete your
profile with your picture or links to
your social media and in even
information about yourself and that will
help us to know who you are and and make
sure that our materials are appropriate
for for your interests so I ask everyone
that already finished their registration
and joining the program to please finish
your profile that will help us as well
now as I mentioned there are going to be
courses in projects these are going to
be somewhat dynamic so we're going to be
adding some new resources here and
you'll see some things appearing and
they say coming soon
throughout the program as we get to that
point they will become available for the
members of the program and we already
added two of these today I'll be doing a
little bit of an analysis from this
project which you'll be able to start
working on after this session it's also
a free project so anyone that's not part
of the program can just explore that
project understand how things work so
you'll see
some material there overall
once everyone starts doing the projects
or working on courses completing those
courses we will be able to understand
the dynamics of this group and will be
able to assist you as you go through the
material so we are trying to develop a
number of tools to help you get through
the material and understand both the
theoretical aspect of what we discuss as
well as the practical so we will be able
to track that kind of activity we have a
progress tab for the members of the
group and we'll be focusing on the
members of the group and every week
discuss the completion of course
material which is going to be in yellow
and the practical assignments which
which will I'll show an example today of
a practical assignment that you'll be
able to complete we do that by looking
at points um so you see here it's going
to be a list of all the participants and
there's going to be some point system
and so how do how are these points
calculated for completing a course you
get 500 points for running a pipeline
and get a hundred points for updating
your profile and get a hundred points
and for group activity you get ten
points
here we obviously just measure your
completion of courses and running
pipelines and what we are generally
interested in is to make sure that you
develop a good sense of not only the
theoretical material that you can read
practically anywhere today there is a
lot of free resources to do that
but also you know how to apply those
tools to a specific challenge that we
first explained and propose as an
exercise which is going to be an
assignment and then learn how to apply
that to your own problem statement so in
the end we also hope that some of you
are going to be advanced enough to be
highlighted after this program is
completed and the benefits of that is
that we believe that all of you or maybe
some of you are interested
to not only learn about these skills but
also become a part of a community a
community that is interested to work
together on bioinformatics projects
perhaps you know you're interested to
get hired by developing bioinformatics
skills so we have a dynamic community of
thousands of participants of previous
programs and other contacts that we have
in different universities and research
labs and there's a high demand for by
informaticians so if you're highlighted
we share that information with our whole
network of over 10,000 contacts and we
hope that that will be useful to you as
well so to look at some of the previous
participants that have been highlighted
there right here on the leader board and
we also have a few blog posts where we
talk about these different members of
different programs that we've done in
the past okay so before I continue I
want to make sure that I've answered any
questions that you might have about the
program the program structure or if
you've you have any question about some
of the login information so if you have
any of those questions please put those
in chat and someone from our team will
actually answer those questions just
check okay
we need to complete all the courses and
pay the additional money for some of
them if you're a participant of the
program there's no more payment for any
of the resources you'll see how all of
those resources are going to be free for
the participants of the program okay so
let's talk about the main topic for
today's session so today we want to talk
about next-generation sequencing in the
context of infectious diseases and we
have some of these topics covered in
today's session which is going to be the
next-generation sequencing reads
sequences what are the file formats that
we're going to be using alignment
annotation on mapped reads and then
alignment on databases of viral genome
so this is what we are going to be
focused on today and I as I mentioned
before we have a full project example on
how to do that using spot a pair of
Krueger berta which is a virus that
infects a line culture that it's used
for vaccine production so it concern for
the FDA but Before we jump to that
project let me kind of introduce
everyone to some of the concepts and the
topics related to next-generation
sequencing so next-generation sequencing
is a popular technique that has been
used a lot for viral bacterial and phage
data and so in 2009 2010 review a
publication that we're going to share
with you in the resources for today's
session there was this chart that was
published where we see that viruses and
bacteria as a percentage of growth and
amount of sequence deposited on public
domain databases has been significantly
higher than mammals and it is important
for us to understand what drives that
trend and one of the important things
that you will discover as you see as the
number of sequences and
being from different viruses is that
primarily this has been driven by
pathogens that caused human disease and
there are you know benefits do that but
also limitations on one hand the benefit
is that we learn a lot more about the
diversity of the viruses that cause
human disease on the other hand we know
that viruses they develop and evolve and
adapt to environmental as well as other
host stresses and so what we still have
as an issue with that is that there's
still a lot of unknowns so we do have a
lot more detailed information genomic
information about pathogens that cause
human disease
we are still limited in how we're able
to understand viruses in general and one
of the reasons for that is that there's
just a lot more viruses than any other
kinds of organisms so that's one of the
reasons however in recent outbreaks we
do see a tremendous growth in both the
generation of genomic data about these
pathogens but also the availability and
the rate of growth for this kind of
information I think this is an important
trend for us to continue and look at
because any kind of research today is
very data-driven and dependent on data
in general and so it's important I think
for all of us involved in this kind of
research to understand how exactly is
next generation sequencing helping
advance this genomic characterization of
viral and bacterial genomes and what we
can do with this kind of information so
I hope that today's session will help us
understand a little bit better
what does all of this mean and what can
we do with this kind of data so today I
wanted to talk about three aspects of
next-generation sequencing in the
context of infectious disease
so an important part of it is the data
preparation so we'll talk a little bit
about different major groups of data
preparation techniques for library
preparation techniques then there are
several methods of analysis so we'll
talk about how this data is analyzed and
of course different methods of
sequencing how different machines
instruments generate the data that we
can analyze so in general there are
three major types of metagenomic and
viral sequencing there's what's called
targeted there is going to be total DNA
or RNA or untargeted and then amplicon
environmental and the differences
between them are that when we look for a
specific type of a pathogen for example
if we're looking for a specific virus
but we expect there to be some diversity
in what we find we can amplify even if
it's a virus with a short genome and
most of the viruses have fairly short
genomes we can amplify for that specific
for those specific genomic regions that
characterize that genome and then what
we expect to find from next-generation
sequencing is some of the diversity that
we will find in the weeds and perhaps
discover that there are some variation
in the one type one strain of a virus
for example that we are looking at
there's also an amplification of
conserved regions so for example
metagenomics is an environmental
approach where you take a sample
directly from the environment that
environment could be from feces it could
be from water it could be from different
soil other types of environmental
samples and we can amplify specific
conserved regions for example with
bacteria they're what's called hyper
variable regions that
want to be unique to bacteria but they
have a certain aspect of variation
throughout the different bacterial
species and families in genera and we
can use that difference by looking at
the composition of the different genomes
that we have environmental sample and
then of course we have the total DNA and
RNA so for example if we take a sample
from a host from an animal or from a
human we can generate the total RNA for
example that is being expressed and we
will find that some of that RNA will
represent some genes coming from
bacteria or from viruses so we can
detect some of the viruses that way as
well in all of these cases we won't have
to have some kind of a set of references
whether those are the amplified regions
whether those are the collection of
genomes that we map on or it's a
database of maybe both or one of those
so some of the examples that again we
will discuss today for example in viral
outbreak methods a lot of times we will
have a direct clinical specimen so for
example we'll have a specimen from a
patient that could be an oral swab and
that could be feces that could be blood
and then within that sequence we are
expecting to find some viral sequence
now the problem is that the quality of
sequencing is directly related to the
amount of virus that we actually have
and typically in a sample like that we
will have a very low amount of virus and
so one of the one important part would
be to simplify that viral sequence and
that's going to be done with PCR where
we will be able to focus on a specific
strain for example if we already have a
clinical information that a person has a
certain virus we might want to amplify
anything related to that viral gene
and then we will be able to study
variation so haplotypes is what we would
call that another way to look at it is
to look for specific sequences that are
typical to the viral polymerase where we
will be able to look at in general what
kinds of viruses are present and so that
is going to be something typical for for
example fecal metagenomic sequencing we
also have the ability to look for
different microorganisms so we will you
might be looking for a combination of
viral and bacterial viral and bacterial
genomes present in a sample where we
might be looking for just detecting for
examples by separating everything that
we have in a sample we can separate for
viral particles for example by their
size or bacteria by their size and then
extracting the DNA or RNA that is
present inside we are able to just focus
the sequencing on those specific RNA or
DNA elements we also might use that to
look for antibiotic resistance so for
example we might be looking for specific
genes not whole genomes but specific
genes for example that are is resistant
to antibiotics and that could be done
for HIV or that could be done for
tuberculosis they both have genes that
are known to have specific mutations
that can indicate resistance
accumulating in the in that specific
host and then we also can look at
microbiome analysis so clinical
metagenomics is ability to look at the
different compositions of the microbiome
and compare them to healthy individuals
so we can look at composition we can
look at presence or absence of specific
families or species of bacteria and by
comparison to understand that something
is not right and then explore exactly
what could be the reason for that and
that could be metagenomic
genomic data or that could be
transcriptomics so we might be looking
at the transcriptomics so the production
of specific genes or we can look at
patients so the host response right
inflammation and different kinds of
genes that are associated with those
processes could be studied at the
transcriptomic level so this is just a
broad overview there's a lot more detail
in the papers that we will share with
you after this session and you can look
a lot more in detail in those
publications how that is done in a
clinical or preclinical studies to
understand for example prevalence of
different viral strains in different
environments and different hosts etc now
I don't want to mention that for those
that are interested to learn about
metagenomics we have a course called
introduction tomato genomics and in
metagenomics one that talks a lot about
the sequencing approaches and some of
the examples of how that sequencing
information is used to study microbiome
or presence of specific types of
bacteria and viruses and we'll do a
little practical example of that today
as well so one of the important aspects
of this kind of metagenomic sequencing
is the ability to look at culture of
free sequencing reads so not have
bacteria first cultured and grown in in
a lab environment that is of course non
natural but looking directly at the
sample and amplifying for those specific
hypervariable regions that could give us
a very good sense of microbiome
composition
now let's talk a little bit about some
of the data formats for sequencing data
the three major formats that we'll talk
about today are the fast cue files the
FASTA files and the GTF files fast queue
files contain sequencing reads and those
sequencing reads have short between 20
and 300 base pair long sequences with
quality information so the queue here
stands for quality something to remember
FASTA files contain the full genomic
information about for example a virus or
a bacteria or even the human genome
could it all be stored in a FASTA format
and typically that would be longer
sequences and those longer sequences
will contain for example information
about different chromosomes and things
like that at a greater detail for
example when we look at specific genes
or variation of those genes isoforms
exons and others that kind of
information will be contained in a GTF
file which is essentially in just a
position of start and end for each
genomic element that we can map the
reach to on the sequence side and then
know some metadata about the segment
that we have covered for example or not
covered so when we talk about having a
viral genome that is produced by
sequencing next-generation sequencing
which by the way not always is produced
by next-generation sequencing from
Illumina it could be other types of
sequencers or even rt-pcr so but when we
talk about next-generation sequencing
this is an example of short reads
aligned to the reference genome of this
novel coronavirus from cobra 2019 and
there's a few things that you see here
including the different reads so the
short lines right here are the different
reads you can see coverage how different
reads are aligned to the reference
genome and you can see that some are
have more coverage than others and then
you see the position on the genome right
here from one to about 30,000 but at the
end what we get and this this
information would be contained in a fast
queue file so all of the reads would be
contained in the fast queue files at the
end of this what we see is typically a
FASTA file so here you see an example of
a FASTA file that has the full genome
and that's just a continuous sequence
even though we know that the genome
contains in specific regions and those
are going to be characterized in a GT AF
file
so again FASTA file is just going to be
a complete sequence and we use it for
reference and the fast queue will have
specific reads plus the quality
information inside each read once we
have this information one of the first
steps that we would typically do is
align those to each other so for example
here you see an alignment to the
reference of individual reads and what
you see is that they stack up right why
do they stack up because they don't all
start at the same beginning but they
eventually stack up and that is what
represents coverage so we will we will
see this in a second how these reads
help us identify changes from the
reference genome and how they can help
us study those specific regions with
greater detail so there's also going to
be two types of sequencing there's
single end read and pair and reads a lot
of the metagenomic sequencing is going
be done with paired-end reads impaired
and read sequencing is more precise
because we have longer reads that are
aligned in different directions to each
other and so we have a higher confidence
in the actual sequence of the read and
we also know where the read ends and
starts and where's the overlap so that's
just something to remember as we will
start uploading files you will see how
it's important to understand whether a
fast queue file was generated from
single end or paired end read sequences
now this as you see is a BAM file right
so it's another file format so what is
this file format the same or the BAM
file which is essentially the same thing
is encoded in such a way that we can
visualize all of the reads so we will
have all of the location the beginning
and the end for each read and how it
aligns to the reference genome so here
you can see an example of a of a number
of reads aligned to a chromosome of the
human chromosome to the genome grch38
and there are some free tools there's
actually many free tools that you can
use to visualize that kind of BAM or Sam
file so after the alignment you will get
a bam or Sam file that you can download
and that is something that you can
either open on your computer I do want
to caution you that those files are
going to be pretty big or you can use an
online visualization solution that will
help you visualize how that works now
what would that look like this is what
it would look like for example as we do
today's assignments we will look at
something that looks like this so what
do we see here we see here actually an
alignment on the tuberculosis genome
which is about 4 million base pairs long
of reeds and
you can see that they accumulate in a
specific region so to know this region
we would have to have the GTF file that
tells us the different genomic elements
in this genome this is called coverage
coverage shows you in general how many
reads cover a specific region and then
you have the actual alignment of reads
and here you can see the blue and the
red which are the two different
directions positive end reads that do
not have a matching pair so the ones
that even though all of this is paired
end reads some of them don't have a pair
okay so this is just a general overview
of the different files the different
formats and an understanding of the
process of alignment so before we move
forward I want to make sure that we
answer any questions and after this if
you have any questions you can put that
in chat after this we will actually do a
practical assignment so that everybody
can get a feel for what this looks like
in real life okay so a question what if
you don't know which virus bacteria is
in the sample so you don't have a
reference that's an excellent question
if you don't know what you're looking
for how do you know that it's there
right and so we will do an example
exactly for that so we will take a meta
genomic sequence that we will align to a
whole database so we'll talk a little
bit about all of the available genomes
are collected on the NCBI virus database
or there are some databases specifically
designed for those hypervariable regions
in bacteria so those are two types of
metagenomic sequences sequencing or
sometimes we will also have for example
a sample from the host transcriptome
right expression of genes and we can
look at not mapped reads the reads that
do not map on the host
a reference genome and then we can look
for viruses or bacteria present in those
as well so we'll talk about these three
different examples now in a second
okay does anyone else have any other
questions about what we talked about so
far and is everyone familiar with with
the different file formats that we've
talked about okay good for another
question SRA found the same to be more
same so SRA file is actually a archive
so it's an archive typically of fast
queue files Sam or BAM files or files
that come out from from alignment so
it's the secondary version of those
files okay so yes if if you do not have
your account information please let us
know okay so for now I'm just going to
share some of the some of the
[Music]
publications that I referenced today so
you can take a look at some of these
publications there's only three I think
they are informative they provide a good
overview for example application of
next-generation sequencing technologies
in biology there is also a publication
here on a diagnostic based on whole
genome sequencing and then a review of
viral metagenomics of course there's a
lot of other useful reference
publications that we'll be talking about
throughout this whole program but this
is something that I wanted to share with
everyone the way that this works is you
can get a Dropbox link basically with
the PDF files there so you don't have to
search for them
I also for this next session will use
several files obviously this is
something that you will be able to use
after you've completed the registration
effectively but some of you might want
to follow along in any case so I'm just
going to paste the link here as well so
and let me explain what are these files
so the second link is the link to the
files so here we have we'll just do a
very basic example but I think it will
give you a sense of how these different
file formats work together and what you
can do with that we have an SRA file
that's essentially a fast cue file
that's compressed of some metagenomic
sequencing there is a reference genome
for Ebola virus and then there's a table
after annotation so this is just a table
of the different found viruses from this
metagenomic sample and we'll do this
analysis together so you get a sense of
how this works
okay so the first step is to get to the
server which will look like this and
this is okay let me exit here actually
this is the link to get to the server so
yes thank you beeps done so if you have
your account you should be locked in
like this you can see my email address
right here and you should be able to get
inside now some of you might have demo
accounts right now if you have a demo
account you can still follow along for
most of the things that we're going to
be doing the only difference is that you
cannot upload any files so really what
we'll be doing today is this section
right here metagenomics microbiome and
if you want to just click through on the
demo you'll be able to click right here
and pressing on these buttons will
explain some of the example data set and
what you can do with that
by clicking on the buttons that show up
after that and yes you will have a copy
of this recording after this session
okay for those of you that do have the
login information if you can click just
right here and by the way if you have
any questions and what these different
sections mean or what they do you can
hover over these little eye icons and
you'll see what they provide inside okay
so the metagenomics microbiome let's do
a brief overview of what we see here on
top we see the option to upload data so
as I mentioned it's important to know do
you have a reference genome that is just
a FASTA file or do you also have a GTF
file it's important to know what kind of
data format you're going to be uploading
for example we'll be using fast queue
files and then paired-end or single and
reads so first of all how do we know
what are we gonna be working with the
file that we'll be using today is a file
taken from NCBI so this is the link to
the file and you can read about the
method of sequencing that they use here
so you can see that this is many genomic
sequencing with spiked primer enrichment
and if you search for this this is an
actual paper that explains how they did
it actually believe this is the paper
right here if you're interested so this
sample right here is a run right so how
do you actually get this file how do you
download it from sra if you click right
here on file and then click here on run
info create a file you will have it will
download a file to your computer
let's take a look at what's inside and
inside you'll find a lot of useful
information of what this file actually
contains so you see that there's a name
there's a release and load date and etc
all kinds of technical information and
then here you'll have a download link so
if you take this link and just copy it
and paste it here and press ENTER it
will download that whole file now that
whole file will come without an ending
it will not have you know dot anything
at the end and so to to fix that you
just have to rename it an add dot s are
a do not change it too fast you make it
dot s array now I already downloaded
that file and put it in Dropbox link so
if you want to just go and take it from
there so for those of you that have
research accounts you can directly
upload this file for those of you that
have an educational account in the next
session I will explain how to manage the
data sets that you will work with
throughout this course it will be using
reference links to data that is already
uploaded so you don't have to actually
upload these big files which are not
allowed with an educational account ok
so just wanted to make sure that all of
that is clear ok let's look at what this
is you can see that the strategy is
amplicon so what they're using is
actually a way to amplify for specific
sequences to be able to detect different
viruses and so here if you read more
about this they were focused on some of
the commonly suspected and dangerous
viruses that you might be wanting to
find and so we'll take a look at how
that works after we run this pipeline
okay another thing to remember here so
let's change this to fast queue another
thing to remember here is what will we
be actually aligning our sequence to and
so here we'll choose virus genomes
because we want to use a database of
virus genomes
okay so this is the analysis that we
will do today can I just ask if you can
let me know that everyone got to this
page on server and is able to log in so
just a few are logged in you can put yes
in chat No
okay so Claudia is not able to log in
grace paducah is not okay so for those
of you that are not able to log in beep
sir if you could just take the names of
the people that still don't have their
login information so we can follow up
with them okay so that's good to know
thank you for letting us know we will
actually go through the list today and
make sure that everybody that has
finalized the registration can log in
and has the information and and then we
will also send you this recording so
that you can try and repeat the steps
that we did here in the so please make
sure that you you know you are getting
emails from marketing at pine pile
without getting those emails you will
not be able to do a lot of things that
we plan for the program okay
so thank you for letting us know okay so
what is this virus database essentially
the database on NCBI has a collection of
all sorts of viruses that people have
submitted from different projects around
the world so one of the requirements for
example for getting grants if you do
kind of any kind of sequencing you have
to submit that's deep lensing and there
are separate repositories so there is a
repository for example for fast queue
files and there's a repository for FASTA
files for assembled genomes there is
also a repository for different
so sequencing of different viruses so
here a couple of links that you can look
at for all the different types of
viruses that are categorized by host by
virus type by type of sequencing etc so
you can take a look at a couple of these
links there's also more structured
database called reference viral database
or VDB which is actually validated and
you will see that validation in the
characterization of these viral
sequences by people is an important part
of having a high quality result in the
end okay so what we will select is virus
genomes which is going to be just that
NCBI virus database okay what will we do
next so just an overview before we
actually go ahead and do it the overview
is we will take this fast queue file so
we upload the SRA the SRA will be
unpacked so unarchive inside that SRA
file this this fast queue file could be
opened in a text format so any text
editor and you will see that inside
there reads and it says what the length
of the read is and has the sequence of
the read and what is the quality of the
sequence and that will be done by the
start button so we'll just do this in a
second together then we will align the
sequences so these read sequences we
will align them to the reference
database and generate an abundance table
and this table will look like this so
we'll actually see here the different NC
is an accession number in the viral
database and we'll be able to look at
these difference names of accession
numbers and understand what kind of
viruses are present in this meta genomic
sequence and so after this we'll do a
different pipeline to actually visualize
what we have found so let's go ahead and
create this pipeline together
okay so we selected here virus genomes
here we have single end because single
in sequencing our model genome we
actually don't need a genome so we're
not going to map it on any kind of
reference and this is fast queue then we
click on file upload here we can use
several ways of uploading in files and
I'll go into more in-depth explanation
of this next time because we're running
out of time but I can essentially upload
a file from my computer from NCBI
directly or using a reference so I'm
just going to put here
okay then you will see that this file
was already uploaded
I don't need I'm not comparing any group
so I'm just going to like cancel when I
press on start it explains how this type
of analysis is done you can see that
some of the buttons light up those are
the ones that are available to me after
the type of data that I upload and the
up and the selection that I do so I will
choose here bow to align I'm going to
align on the reference database and then
I'm going to just generate a table that
shows me all of the presents viruses
that I have and I'll click on end so
after I create my pipeline I can name it
and so if you want us to help you by
tracking your pipeline just keep this
name somehow relevant and easier to find
there's a lot of you and we will be
taking the time to review these
pipelines so for example I'll name mine
Yuliya you know pipeline metagenomics
and then you'll be able to run your
pipeline so don't forget you don't just
create a pipeline and leave you have to
run the pipeline yeah so the reference
for demo was actually a different file
again what we will use today is
[Music]
you
one seconds
yeah for those of you that have an
educational account you have to you have
to use the svl um yeah so I will
actually email you a clear direction on
how to do this I just had it saved for
me but I'll email you a link and then
you run the pipeline okay so after you
run that pipeline I'm not gonna do it
because I already ran the pipeline so I
just wanted today to kind of give
everybody an overview of how this works
so let's take a look at my pipelines
you'll see for example that I ran this
pipeline right here and and right now
I'll actually give you that link so you
can see that I ran this pipeline here I
have all of the links that I used here
so let me quickly give you that link
this is a link to all of the repository
files okay and actually it is Ricky so
for those of you that wanted to run this
pipeline if you do have an educational
account that is where that fast queue
file is
or that is where there's a raise but
what happens is essentially it extracts
this array and creates a fast queue file
that's a file that you can use okay and
let's take a look at what's in the
actual main output here so you would go
to download the main download folder and
you have a few different files that are
output here so you can see that there's
going to be an annotation file there's
going to be mapping statistics and this
is the table that we're looking for so
what is inside that table as I explained
there's going to be a list of the
different viral sequences that were
found after you map and what you can do
is you can just go and take this nc
accession number go to NCBI select your
nucleotide because that's where it came
from and search for that for that
accession number so here for example
that this is a phage right what is the
phage is some virus that infects
bacteria so these are going to be the
most present ones and eventually as you
go through you will see that some of the
human viruses are also going to be
present here in the sequence so what's
important for us is that we have found
one of these that is going to be very
concerning right it's Ebola so we
actually found a presence of some Ebola
virus in a sequence and so that's a
concern for us so what we want to do
next is we want to take all of these
reads and map them onto the reference of
Ebola virus okay just to understand what
portion of that was covered right and so
let's just do that quickly together so
we understand how that works that could
be done in a number of different
sections but what we will do is we will
go to a section dedicated to analysis of
genomic data so right here in their
genomics epigenetics right we expect
this to be a sequence of a gene
so we'll go to mutation variant parallel
analysis of mutation variant data again
these are se so single end we will only
do an reference genome we're not going
to upload a GTF file and then this is
going to be a fast queue file notice
that you can also upload here say more
bam files okay let's go to file upload
so now we use that link that I gave you
again sorry this link that I pasted it
in chat right we just pasted it right
here and now we need to upload and this
will be allowed for your educational
account as well but it's a small file
it'll actually upload the Ebola virus so
where is that Ebola virus that is in the
Dropbox folder that I gave you
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
data and then you'll see that there is a
genome from Ebola is a year from 2015 so
you choose that file you see that it's
uploaded to a hundred percent and then
you can do continue and we actually
don't need any groups because we're not
comparing any sequences we will do that
next time we'll compare sequences but
here all we want to do is upload our
data and then map it on to the reference
genome this time because we already
detected that that genome is there by
mapping on a database of viruses we'll
click on save and we'll just click on
visualization so we'll visualize how do
the reads that we have map on this
reference database and then you click on
end and again remember to save the
pipeline was some kind of a name again
I'm not going to run this myself because
I already ran it what instead I want to
do is show you the output as we're
approaching the end of this session okay
so here's the pipeline just exactly like
what I showed you right we upload the
data map on the reference genome
generate a visualization and click on
end and then here you will have a link
to visualization and that visualization
is using J browse and it looks like this
okay remember this is to illustrate what
type of sequencing technique was used
here so this is an amplicon sequencing
technique what it does is it amplifies
certain regions that are specific to the
viral polymerase of different viruses
that we're we're careful not to have in
typical patient samples and here's what
you can see as the result so this is the
reference genome ln8 seven seven nine
fifty five point one it is the sequence
of Ebola virus which is about nineteen
thousand faces nineteen thousand bases
long and these are this is the coverage
so very small coverage right across this
short section of the reference genome if
we zoom in
you can actually see start seeing the
sequence down here okay and I'm just
going to give you the link to this
visualization if you want to explore and
not wait for your pipeline so this is
the the link if you just click on that
link you should be able to see what I
see so please let me know if you're able
to see that
it will take a little bit of time to
load but you should be able to see it
you
you
all right great Thank You Martin so this
is Jay brows Jay brows is one of those
free tools that you can use to visualize
the results of alignment on a reference
genome right now we took a very simple
analysis right all we did was we mapped
a short portion of those reads that we
downloaded from NCBI onto the Ebola
virus genome great looks like everybody
is able to see it so just let's make
sure that we understand what we see here
we see a very small number of reads and
those reads are aligned to the reference
genome and here we see the total
coverage for this portion here we see
the reference genome sequence and
remember that these are nucleotides that
are translated to amino acids and so the
changes in different nucleotides will
cause a change potentially in the amino
acid and that is going to be the
functional structural change so we'll
talk a lot about all of these different
things later but what was important in
this session is for us to be able to get
to this point and know that one we
understand the different file formats so
what format are we looking at let me ask
you this question what are we seeing
here visualized what file format
is it the GTF file is it the FASTA file
is it the fast queue file or is it the
BAM file BAM
alright gif Bam Bam Bam yes so the
correct answer is BAM thank you for
answering those of you that are looking
at some of the other ones let's just
quickly review so yes you have elements
from the GTF file that are actually not
uploaded right so if we did upload a GTA
file we would see here position of
individual genes so we don't have the
GTF file this is what's inside the FASTA
file is just this sequence right here
what's inside the fast queue file just
these individual reads but the BAM file
as you can see right here BAM alignment
right that aligns these different fast
queue sequences to the FASTA reference
genome and provides us with a sense of
coverage excellent so all of you now
understand next-generation sequencing
all of you now know what we're looking
at let's go back to our presentation so
we're running out of time so I'm just
going to run through some of the other
slides that I had here so what we what
you can do to go through this process
and detail again and look at how this is
applied to one example is to look at
this project on spot-up Terrafugia
pirita which is a viral contamination of
a cell line that is used for the
production of biologics biologics can
include insulin as a biologic or a
vaccine as a biologic right so different
types of naturally occurring proteins
that are produced using cell lines this
is a project that describes how you can
understand contamination and how you can
use the exact same type of analysis that
we did here by mapping on a reference
database finding what types of viruses
could be present and how do we know what
is actually of
CERN using that example okay so this is
a free course those of you that have
registered for the program can take it
those of you that have not yet
registered and want to get a better
sense of what we're gonna be doing you
can also take that project as well what
are we going to cover in our next
session as you saw some of those
positions were highlighted right some of
those positions look like they were
different from the reference genome so
we're going to talk about multiple
sequence alignment next time how are we
going to use this information that we
have of all of the reads and all the
reference genome nucleotide sequences to
understand variation and doing that
using multiple sequence alignments again
it's going to be a practical session
we'll do a little bit of an introduction
I ask that by next time for those of you
that are not familiar with the
nucleotides or amino acids or you know
some of these sequencing formats you
start looking at some of those courses
that we have we have several courses
that could be helpful introduction to
genomics genomics one could be helpful
transcriptomics one could be helpful for
understanding different formats as well
so started taking a look at those
courses as part of Terrafugia we'll
cover some of this as well so you can
take a look at that what did we learn in
this session in this session we looked
at sequencing what our reads how is this
sequencing done what are some of the
different file formats how is alignment
performed we talked a little bit about
how we have different types of reads
some of them maps and them don't map and
how do we map on the databases of viral
genomes I hope that this was helpful and
gives you a good review of some of the
basic terms and do you feel more ready
for the program as we're getting started
here at this point if you have any
questions I'm happy to spend another few
minutes to answer any questions that you
may
do the pipeline will do assembly and
annotation at the same time if we use
the reference genome okay so those are
two different two different things that
need to be done when we just have one
reference genome we are not doing
assembly we're actually just mapping
reads on the best location on that
reference genome when do we do need to
use assembly when we have a database of
genomes there is going to be a lot of
similar sequences in the different
genomes and to find the best position
the longer the sequence that we're
trying to map the best we can evaluate
what is the optimal mapping and so
that's when assembly is me another way
we can think about assembly is when we
look at transcriptomic data we actually
have to assemble the transcriptome to
understand what kinds of expression of
isoforms and another variation happens
so assembly is a little bit of a
different approach
what assembly does is looks at
overlapping weeds or reads that contain
elements of each other and combines them
into context so these are continuous
sequences assembled from multiple weeds
there's a number of different approaches
for that that we'll talk a little bit
more later but those are separate tasks
and not always used together okay any
any other questions okay if anyone has
any technical questions how to register
how to make sure that you can access
your account how to upload files
anything like that please ask feature
marketing at Pine dot bio Thank You
Beatrice right there this recording will
be posted on the forum this recording
and the previous recording will also be
posted on the forum
okay another quick question here faster
files are they created by the user so
someone who does the sequencing creates
a fast queue file and then that fast
queue file could be assembled into a
genome and that would be a FASTA file
those assembled genomes are typically
curated by people that check those files
and understand how they were assembled
etc sometimes faster files could be
created from rt-pcr they could be
created from other types of like saying
your sequencing etc so there's many
different ways to generate a faster file
which is a sequence of a genome or a
region that is submitted to ncbi okay so
if you have any technical questions
please ask beach to email us if you are
already in the program please update
your profile make sure that we actually
have your real name and any information
you would like to share with us you will
see how this will become useful as we
progress in this program we have
provided you with access to some of the
course material and project materials so
please take a look at that and we look
forward to seeing you again next time
which is going to be which is going to
be May 7th so we will look forward to
seeing you um May 7th again it's going
to be on zoom' so please join us next
time thank you everyone for joining
today thank you
you